[Musique]
donc il ya peut-être des descendants
mais surtout il ya des dirigeants sans
cran je voulais pas qu'on me renvoie la
gueule vous fait ça pour le pognon et
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
immédiatement dit je me moque flics
parce que je voulais pas qu'on y revient
de dire tous pareils ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la place et tout ça moi
je ne cherche pas à faire un cas une
provocation un cas d'école comme on
l'entend je je je je vais je vais
remettre mon pull pour la suite des
débats
un show pognon journalistes ils
travaillent d'abord ici dans sa ville
d'amiens sur les effets tragiques de la
désindustrialisation
après le succès de son film merci patron
il devient député et tente à sa façon la
politique autrement
mais peut-on cas c'est comme ça les
codes de la politique dire ce qu'on
pense comme on le pense face à un
président qui lui aussi innovent cette
semaine nous déshabillons en tout bien
tout honneur l'insoumis françois ruffin
[Musique]
françois ruffin bonjour on est ici chez
vous à amiens vous y passez beaucoup de
temps depuis que vous êtes député
j'essaie d'être là du vendredi au lundi
ça marche pas toujours mais en gros
d'avoir trois 3 jours à l'assemblée
nationale mardi mercredi jeudi et quatre
jours chez moi alors vous poser de
questions parce que vous avez été assez
actif quand même un ces derniers temps à
l'assemblée nationale avec voilà parfois
des démarches à 6 que nos classes est un
jeu reprend cette image qu'est ce
qu'elle dit cette image se joue porte
d'abord le maillot de l'équipe du rif
qui est une équipe d'amiens nord est le
fait de porter devant les caméras le
maillot d'une équipe populaire comme ça
c'est un signe qui envoyait que de
l'intérêt qu'on leur porte et que
j'aimerai bien que la représentation
nationale les ministères et l'état porte
le même intérêt parce que vous avez fait
enfin c'était pour défendre
effectivement une proposition de loi
dans députés d'un parlementaire hit i d
i michel zumkeller est en fait cette
proposition de loi est là et et on va
dire médiatisée il ya une espèce de coup
de pub que vous avez fait voilà devant
devant l'hémicycle ne pensait que la pum
ce coup de pub c'est assez un élément
important déterminant pour parler d'eux
pour avoir fait parler de ce texte
bah oui c'est évident qu'on bon ça peut
être touché un sujet qui est populaire
qui est déjà le football ou le sport en
général ça c'est le choc
après il ya un deuxième principe qui est
pas un principe très politique mais
c'est pas s'ennuyer dire que l'assemblée
nationale peut être un lieu du grand
ennui sans doute la vie politique en
général avec des tas de réunions des
discours comptable ou alors très techno
avec des articles de loi enfin bon ça
peut être très gonflé en quoi et donc je
préfère avoir des ennuis qu'avoir
l'ennui et jl ya cette phrase de
chansons de boby lapointe
j'ai chanté i de maintenant ma vie un
petit brin de fantaisie youpi youpi
sachant que ça c'était pas votre
proposition doit cesser nos
parlementaires oui vous avez réfléchi
ensemble ils étaient c'était à moi je
viens d'abord quand j'ai signé la
proposition j'ai mis cinq minutes à la
signer parce que je trouvais que c'était
une excellente proposition de loi donc
de taxer les transferts des gros
transferts notamment des matières le
football un petit peu en matière de
rugby aussi et de reverser sa hausse
perd port amateur et je trouve moi très
marrant d'avoir des axes comme ça un peu
inattendue entre insoumis érudit et nos
julie ben voilà ce que tu veux qu'on
fasse un peu de com autour
moi je
c'est mon savoir faire voilà on va on va
aller se taper des jongles dans la cours
de l'assemblée nationale on verra bien
si on est viré par de rugy ou pas donc
on a fait ça ensuite j'ai proposé que
c'est un petit mais la première fois il
s'agit donc là il voulait pas trop
enfiler un maillot de foot puis là
c'était la deuxième fois donc il enfile
la deuxième fois il a une maillot de
foot voilà là il dribble avait vu il
jongle bon et puis je pense que on en
est content tous les deux parce que
c'est un juste humainement c'est des
moments à vivre
on peut parler de politique qu'est ce
que ça change pour le pays et tout ça il
faut espérer que ça changera questionne
un jour là c'est pas immédiat mais soit
on s'ennuie on porte tristement les
choses soit on essaye de mettre un peu
de d'énergie et d'envié dans nos vie
quoi alors là ça marche
effectivement on parle de la proposition
doit à cette séance de dribble devant
l'assemblée nationale etc
le lendemain vous arrivez dans
l'hémicycle avec le maillot de foot et
alors là vous avez un rappel à l'ordre
une amende finalement est-ce que c'est
pas le
c'est pas la limite a pas franchir
finalement de détourner le sujet de
partir sur finalement un problème
vestimentaire dans l'hémicycle moi je
suis très fier d'avoir porté ce maillot
là qui est maillot du club de au cours
sur somme
mais vous dites pas assez contre femmes
comme vous dites là comme c'est un peu
mon truc c'est ce que j'ai appris à zoug
keller l'autre parlementaire est ce que
vous vous dites pas voilà il ya là comme
efficace qui met le zoom sur l'action il
ya la qualification mais finalement ça a
marché
ah bon avant ça a marché ben oui c'est
évident pourquoi ça marche on a parlé de
votre maillot de foot dresde a quand
même regarder le regarder d'autres
voulaient que j'aille chercher le
courrier picard du jour vous l'avez
acheté à côté à acheter toute la presse
sauf le cohiba l'art du jour c'est
françois ruffin défend le sport amateur
et on remet ça parle du maillot mais bon
voilà donc ça a mené vers autre chose
ce que je vois c'est même cae le jeu ne
se demandait si l'amendé pas contre
productive dans quelle mesure ça se
heurtent l'institution mais ça ne sorte
pas les gens dans quelle mesure ce jeu
cet accord dont vous revendiquez les
deux trois nuits c'était c'était de la
bonne comme pour vous même si vous
pourrez dire face à hearts en août
françois de rugy et puis des
parlementaires à l'intérieur de
l'institution il ya sans doute des
citoyens qui sont pas content non plus
moi je pense que dans l'ensemble on va
s'en sortir pour vous exprimer
vous avez le maillot de foot vous avez
aussi une chaîne youtube un très nourris
avec de nombreuses vidéos et à la une
qui nous a intrigués qui est rare un
poste assez rare chez un politique qui a
beaucoup fait réagir je vous montre la
france a soumis ce peut être la première
reconnue comme la première force
d'opposition et en même temps je suis
pas sûr que les gens donner les clés du
pays
volontiers pour le gouverner ils doivent
se dire quelque part ils sont pas prêts
ils sont pas à la hauteur enfin je sens
quelque chose comme ça quoi on est bien
en opposition ça ça on est très bien là
mais et moi même j'éprouve un certain
vertige à l'idée qu'on puisse détenir le
pouvoir
on va attendre dans une situation
conflictuelle vachement forte avec des
gens qui seront pas préparé à ce niveau
de pouvoir
deux responsabilités donc vraiment pour
moi c'est vertigineux l'idée qu'on
puisse se dire que demain nous
gouvernons vertigineux dites vous mais
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
autres insoumis ne sont pas d'accord du
tout à commencer par le premier d'entre
eux jean luc mélenchon ça prouve qu'il
n'a pas le melon françois comme d'autres
dans groupe sont des gens qui ont eu un
itinéraire l'unité journalier et des
documentaires engagés
il était engagé mais solitaire tandis
que le groupe est composé de gens qui
ont des années de luttes en paquets
quand j'ai fait la campagne
présidentielle par exemple pourquoi je
dis ça parce qu'il dit il faudrait qu'on
gagne dans les grandes écoles mais s'est
fait simplement françois n'a pas
participé à cette étape du travail ne la
connais pas donc je le rassure c'est un
garçon modeste qui lui n'est pas dans la
volonté tout le temps évidemment il est
face aux difficultés et ce serait d
énormes difficultés sans aucun doute
pour autant n'en tirons pas la
conclusion que d'autres seraient plus
prêts que nous on part donc d'annuler
françois tétreault modeste wii nommé
voiliers mais c'est ce qui fait sa
marque et c'est un gentil garçon un
gentil garçon modeste mon baptême qui a
dit une connerie enfin c'est ce qu'on
comprend parler d'abord c'est à qui on
s'adresse donc je suis sur ma chaîne
youtube
je m'adresse à un public qui est
vraisemblablement plus militant et moi
si je d'abord si je fais cette vidéo là
si je dis ça c'est pas parce que j'ai
pas le moral c'est parce que j'ai le
moral
j'ai lu 18 ans de journalisme à mon
actif 18 ans de contre-pouvoir local et
national
mais la question la possibilité voire la
probabilité qu'on parvienne au pouvoir
que la gauche dont je suis parvient à ne
pouvoir jusqu'à maintenant elle n'était
pas posée aujourd'hui elle est posée
comme une possibilité pour moi en effet
il ya à côté vertigineux à se dire que
demain on il possible qu'on gouverne
voilà sa première choisi la deuxième
chose c'est que j'avance avoir tout moi
j'adore ça m'est en mon for intérieur
mes doutes mes hésitations mais
incertitudes sur la table et non pas en
disant voilà je suis super fort on va y
arriver non c'est à dire que si on veut
pour moi avec les gens franchir les
obstacles qui sont sur notre chemin
il faut les connaître il faut les
énoncés il faut il faut se dire comment
on va les contourner mon peuvent pas
faire comme si on les y
oui donc voilà donc oui donc vous
avancez à voix haute mais en même temps
vous poser cette vidéo juste quelques
heures avant voilà le grand
rassemblement de la france a soumises
donc quelque part c voilà vous avez
l'habitude de là comme vous l'avez dit
c'est quand même un message politique
aussi à l'attention des insoumis nom est
derron voit bien qu'ils ont réagi mais
parce que ce centre est et dont vous
êtes un peu la voix dissonantes vous
êtes un peu il ya bien un sens quand
même quand vous faites c'est moi le sens
il est clair c'est que la sunna dessus
c'est 'qui je pose des questions aux
mouvements france insoumise le moment de
combat c'est quand il ya des élections
et là il n'y a pas de place pour le
doute c'est comme un athlète qui courent
où l'un est relatif quand ce n'est pas
le moment lui dire m'attends à ce que tu
vas vraiment y arriver et tout ça non là
aujourd'hui on est plus dans une phase
de combats intenses
on a le droit de se poser des questions
sur comment se structure quelles sont
nos objectifs intermédiaires
comment on va franchir un certain nombre
d'obstacles oui d'accord mais en même
temps ça sert à quoi ça sert à quoi de
dire ça à ce moment là et au vu de la
réaction que ça suscite est ce que
vraiment ça ça sert à quelque chose
comme ça d'avancé à voix haute ce qui
était une méthode assez rare en
politique c'est ça qui est intéressant
je pense que si on si on énonce pas les
questions et les problèmes on va pas les
résoudre
donc voilà maintenant il ya aussi autre
chose c'est que la vidéo elle est plus
longue que ça oui ce que non mais voilà
ce que nous ayons ce que j'ai dit est
payé beaucoup plus nuancée que l'extrait
qui est retenu et que évidemment ce qui
sort dans les médias et ce qui est
montré pourquoi bien ou mélenchon c'est
ce qui est retenu et donc et moi il
réponde à ça et de répondre à ça when we
were répondre à ça et je le pense je
peux en effet il ya quelque chose que
parfois je ne mesure pas dans la
dynamique médiatique
moi je veux dire que depuis je suis
entrée à l'assemblée nationale ce qui
m'a le plus surprise sur les médias
c'est la capacité à parfois se focaliser
sur un petit quelque chose parfois ça
s'échappe et donc ça devient
une pelote médiatique ah d'accord c'est
ça que vous avez découvert sur le
fonctionnement des médias ça vous
ignorez j'avais sur le plan théorique
j'étais très fort mais bah oui mais
anticiper un cri mais je souhaitais une
école de journalisme écrit sur les
médias les petits soldats du journalisme
enfin bon c'est sympa mais c'est bien
quand même passer de la théorie à la
pratique c'est quelque chose et une
banque d'être l'objet je l'aï maintenant
j'étais un jeu j'étais journaliste
j'aurais été quelque part de l'autre
côté de la barrière mais se retrouver
obligé médiatique
c'est quelque chose qui est une
expérience et je libère
par exemple j'ai deux moments qui mois
dans le fonctionnement médiatique m'a
permis aux portugais ont surpris c ra
soir je fais une intervention sur les
liens entre macro et lagardère et c'est
une intervention très orageuse qui
suscite l'ire de la foi dans marche des
républicains et tout ça et je sors et je
vois que sur les sites internet
le seule chose qui a été retenue c'est
une chemise qu'il n'est pas du pantalon
bon et ça c'est quelque chose que je ne
maîtrise absolument pas il ya un
deuxième
on dira que vous avez remis votre
chemise dans votre pantalon pour pas
polluer le message d'ailleurs oui oui
voilà c'est absolument pas maîtrisé toi
voulons faire rejoint la question que je
posais sur le maillot est ce que parfois
ça polypes al alagi absolument aucune
volonté
bon voilà et là il ya un deuxième moment
si je pose une question à edouard
philippe sur la d paquin
sa réponse est complètement à côté de la
plaque je pense qu'on a la possibilité
d'une confrontation sur le fond et je
sors de la salle des quatre colonnes que
d'habitude j'ai vite en me disant cette
fois ci je vais y aller et on me tend le
micro onde dim
qu'est ce que vous pensez du drapeau
européen bon ben voilà c'est des moments
qui sont en reste pour moi quand même
d'accord nos jours bien réagir sur
complètement autre chose d'accord réagit
pas quand même il ya quelque chose qui
est que dit jean luc mélenchon lors déjà
la question ça pose si quand on voit là
il a l'air un peu énervé jean luc
mélenchon on a l'impression que c'est il
sourit mais avec des yeux qui sont quand
même assez brillant de colas on retrouve
sympa et se retrouve saint-palais là il
pourrait très bien
franchement il raconte des conneries ces
voix là il voulait pas dire non mais je
trouve qu'il est très tolérant sur en
effet la latitude qui mais l'essai et
qui est quand même assez important qui
n'est quand il dit quelque part en fait
c'est que vous êtes un pain d'électron
libre des politiques que vous n'avez pas
ce parcours d'élaboration des programmes
des réflexions des propositions et
quelque part il dit voilà un nous on l'a
fait vous vous ne l'avez pas fait et
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose qui vous
manquent
est-ce que vous n'êtes bien sûr mais ce
n'est pas quelque chose moi il manque
des tas de trucs des centaines de truc
qui me manque mais je le vois bien en
effet que j'ai une démarche qui est qui
a été beaucoup plus individuelle je dis
toujours moi je alors moi me dit d'un
côté il ya eu un groupe qui a travaillé
six mois je veux si je pense que quand
même il nous reste des démarches à
monter pour être
en responsabilité mais on a du temps
pour les monter moi c'est le message que
je passe dans ma vidéo c'est de dire
voilà la marche est haute mais on a
maintenant du temps devant nous et on
est en train de faire le travail de
gagner en responsabilités moi j'avais
jamais déposé une proposition de loi
gens déposent une ou deux là pour la
première fois donc c'est un chemin de se
dire comment faire rentrer ça dans
l'école les machins les trucs et dire
moi je sais pas en même temps aussi les
sens de la politique dans notre système
politique mais moi le moi je et peut
être soit comme une marque de
l'égocentrisme et il peut être vu aussi
comme une preuve de modestie
c'est à dire que quand je m'exprime je
sais que c'est en mon nom personnel que
je m'exprime et qui peut y avoir des
gens qui se reconnaissent dans cette
parole mais qui est une parole
singulière et donc une parole singulier
et c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup plus de
mal à dire nous parce que c'est pas
comme si j'avais incorporer des
programmes défunt voyez je suis pas
d'accord c'est pas le jeu et gothique
comme certains parce que certains
parlent de votre humanité avec jean luc
mélenchon en disant vous parlez de vous
faire je me barre et de tout ce qui me
manque c'est pas moi c'est jean luc
mélenchon massivement pas un truc mais
moi je pense qu'il manque un truc qui
manque beaucoup de trucs et peut-être
que si ça fait mon originalité de qu'il
manque des trucs et qui me disent qu'ils
manquent des trucs ma famille mais je
veux dire que je vois je sais que je ne
suis pas aujourd'hui un homme d'état on
va pas se la raconter je suis pas ça
jonah un agitateur un animateur de la
démocratie je suis ça j'espère l'être je
jette pertes à être un bon porte parole
des gens c'est marrant parce que vous
avez parlé de de votre face à face avec
edouard philippe dans l'hémicycle on
l'avait retenu mais justement pour ans
pour en montrer autre chose et
c'est ce rôle que vous voulez savoir qui
est le rôle un peu de caillou dans la
chaussure je crois que c'est ce que vous
aviez dit quand vous vous êtes présenté
à la députation est alors pour rappeler
les choses aux téléspectateurs le rôle
de caillou dans la chaussure c'est ce
que vous avez toujours jouer et
notamment avec ce documentaire merci
patron pour lequel vous aviez un césar
le césar du meilleur documentaire je
remonte un petit extrait de votre
discours le soir de la cérémonie
mon film il parle d'une usine qui part
en pologne et qui laisse derrière un
paquet de misère et un paquet de
détresse et au moment où je vous parle
c'est une usine d'amiens qui s'appelle
des usines whirlpool amiens qui fabrique
des sèche-linge qui subit la même
histoire puisque maintenance sa part
paul a aussi en pologne
pourquoi ça dure comme ça depuis 30 ans
ça dure quoi comme ça depuis 30 ans
parce que ce sont des ouvriers qui sont
touchés et donc on en a rien à si
c'était des acteurs qui étaient mis en
concurrence de la même manière avec des
acteurs roumains
ça pose des problèmes immédiatement ça
c'était le caillou dans la chaussure aux
césar je vous propose maintenant de
regarder le caillou dans la chaussure
face à edouard philippe
monsieur le premier ministre le jeudi 20
juillet vous rendiez en catimini sur un
site sanofi de vitry vous étiez
accueillis par sont peinés chez sert van
berg
vous n'aviez prévenu nuit les médias ni
les syndicats ni les salariés ni les
français
cette visite discrète sinon secrètes ne
figurait pas à votre agenda
avant vous le 14 mai dernier emmanuel
macron entrée à l'elysée lors de cette
cérémonie le nouveau président fendez la
foulée venez salue un vieil ami le même
serge weinberg pdg de sanofi vous savez
que ces dernières années sanofi à
supprimer 2000 postes de chercheurs en
france 4000 dans le monde et en même
temps sanofi après aperçu des centaines
de millions crédit impôt recherche
vous savez surtout surtout qu'on recense
environ 14000 familles victimes de la
dea paquin des milliers d'enfants
autistes
le coût de leurs adhérents pénalisation
s'élèvera à au moins six milliards
d'euros et en même temps sanofi refuse
de participer au fonds la firme en
laisse l'entière charge à l'état c'est
le contribuable qui paiera avec vos
insinuations élégante
vous êtes en train si je vous comprends
bien monsieur le député
de considérer qu' il serait normal pour
la représentation nationale
normal pour le chef du gouvernement de
ce pays deux dans toute la mesure du
possible dénigrait une entreprise
française
une entreprise qui fonctionne bien une
entreprise qui crée des richesses en
france et qui apporte des solutions sur
les questions de la santé
oui monsieur rufin je vous le confirme
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
permettez moi monsieur rufin permettez
moi de terminer ma question ça n'est pas
parce qu'on crie qu'on a raison il va
falloir vous y faire
nous dans cette altercation ce qu'on a
trouvé intéressant en revoyant c'est
qu'en fait il répond pas du tout à votre
question et ce tous les mercredis ça
ouais c'est tous les mercredis mais
alors la question qu'on se pose c'est
pourquoi il ne répond pas à votre
question est ce que c'est parce que
quelque part vous faites un peu un effet
en expliquant voilà le voyage en
catimini macro qui va saluer etc et vous
évoquez cette dissimulation et du coup
se polarise là dessus pour pas répondre
à la question technique qu'est ce que
c'est pas ça qui joue aussi c'est qu'il
répond un peu à l'effet de manche il
répond pas à la question pas bon je veux
revenir sur nos petits cailloux dans la
chaussure
- soly scrupules en latin et moi c'est
un moment important pour moi parce que
en fait être un petit caillou dans leur
conscience
voilà c'est ça l'objectif ensuite là
dessus c'est je pense qu'il ya deux
arènes toujours au sein de l'hémicycle
il ya la reine dans l'hémicycle où on
peut avoir l'impression qu'on perd parce
que les députés se lèvent et
applaudissent et tout ça edouard tu dis
qu'il a fait sa réponse dont il est très
fier grosso modo on ne doit pas dénigrer
l'entreprise française je suis désolé
c'est un effet de boomerang
parce que là ça marche peut-être dans
l'hémicycle est-ce que sur les réseaux
sociaux ça marche
ce qu'on ne doit pas dénigrer une
entreprise française donc il a répondu à
la question il a répondu à la question
sur ses liens très forts avec
cette fusion et confusion avec les
grandes entreprises françaises ça veut
dire que pour vous quelque part si les
missiles c'est une tribune com com vous
plaisent même que vous auriez pu
utiliser avant faisant des documentaires
en faisant des films quand vous vous
adressez au gouvernement vous utilisez
les missiles comme une tribune en fait
c'est évidemment une tribu mais ce ne
fut pas seulement pour moi c'est une
tribune pour tout le monde d'autant plus
que le parlement étant vidé de sa
fonction législative parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'exécutif qui
balancent des textes ainsi pas nouveau
oui et non mais l'accord n'ont passé
comme ça donc il faut l'admettre
qu'est ce qu'il reste comme fonction il
reste en effet la fonction tribunitienne
donc c'était le cas en plus là on est
dans une prise à partie nulle
gouvernement dans et c'est évidemment
retransmit sur votre chaîne d'ailleurs
donc c'est pas si à ce moment là on
n'utilise pas la tribune
autant rester chez soi quoi alors ce qui
est intéressant d'ailleurs ses clés face
à face là on a vu celui avec edouard
philippe
il y en a eu aussi à répétition avec
emmanuel macron autour de la
délocalisation de l'usiné mère-poule
inde que vous aviez évoqué avant et
alors ce qui se passe c'est que là il ya
une espèce de à piennes puisque en fait
l'usiné et reprise donc une partie des
emplois sont sauvés
emmanuel macron se rend sur place 1 va
visiter les usines et vous êtes avec lui
à ce moment là bas ce sont les plus
jeunes qui n'ont pas pu être annoncée de
l'année on s'est engagés n'ont pas pu
construire leur maison donc appelé son
ami le savez que je retrouve à poil
aller sur scène c'est pour ça que je
n'avais jamais entendu défendre et
l'intérim il est contraint clown et la
précarité
je vois là je vous le redonne le ballon
je ne sois pas les oubliés de cette idée
fend de leurs droits on passe le
recensement face to pay puis les
défendre lente alors aidez moi de faire
le rencensement deuxième devant 2 duo on
a un peu l'impression d'être ce que vous
dites le matin même à la radio c'est que
vous accompagnez un peu
le verre à moitié plein finalement
emmanuel macron vient récolter les
fruits de cette politique vous vous êtes
là vous l'accompagnez et alors quel
effet ça renvoie je voulais vous faire
réagir aux commentaires d'un communicant
de nous avons sollicité et philippe
lentschener qui a notamment travaillé
avec arnaud montebourg
qu'est ce que ces confrontations
produisent je me fais écouter sa
réaction
françois ruffin et de cette nouvelle
école de journalisme qu'on voit fleurir
un petit peu de ce journalisme
alternatif
vous avez des gens qui apostrophe des
politiques et qui engagent des débats et
des discussions
donc il fait ça lui il fait ça la seule
chose c'est qu'il a face à lui un
président de 38 ans qui est de cette
culture et donc qu'ils acceptent la
discussion et qui débat une fois qui
l'apostrophé son son partenaire du coup
parce que ça devient du partenariat on
n'est pas loin du divertissement
une fois qu'ils apostrophé son
partenaire et qu' il est bien conscient
que le sujet sur lequel il voulait
mettre le doigt a bien été sous les feux
des projecteurs
si la face à lui quelqu'un qui n'a pas
peur de ce débat qu'ils ne fuient pas
ben brusquement le truc tourne en rond
parce que comme vous n'allez jamais vous
ne portez pas le fer dans la plaie c'est
à dire que vous n'allez pas ensuite
avoir des solutions
vous n'allez pas proposer quelque chose
donc en fait l'autre y discute et à un
moment donné faut bien arrêter il faut
bien rompre la discussion et donc elles
seront sur l'un qui a gagné et l'autre
cas perdu et qui gagne et qui perd qui
gagne le président les gagne parce qu'il
n'a pas baissé la tête et il a discuté
donc en cela il a témoigné d'une
compréhension de la vie que les gens
vivent et il prend date et rendez vous
c'est sa fonction qui peut prendre date
et rendez vous et l'autre il n'a rien
arrachés il n'a rien gagné et donc je
pense qu'à terme ce type de
fonctionnement va créer un petit peu de
désenchantement tant pour lui que pour
les gens qui l'écoutent
parce qu'on se dira que au delà de du
happening il se passera de quoi ce que
je vous propose c'est de venir parler à
des personnes qui sont en crèche les
voyages oui mais vous n'avez venez avec
moi aujourd'hui je
invitent à venir les rencontrer ça fait
un petit détour dans le circuit de comme
la communication l'expert du carton
d'accord je ne vais pas vous qu'on y va
enchaîner mais les contrats et des jeux
des verrait jeu nous les traitons mais
je vais vous dire fath responsable
500000 2016 ces cinq cent mille contrats
aidés à dire c'est les à cent mille
emplois financés par le public jetable
mais monsieur macondo moi je veux la
forme allant dont on va y avait bien des
médias et il ya des états unis je veux
le soin d'informer de contrats aidés ce
que je faisais ce que je dis dans les
pages à vis des médias qui le souhaitent
à venir voir montrer ce type est un
média ambulants mais il n'est pas un
politique il 9 donne et ne fait aucune
concession à la politique ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'en fait pas de politique
mais il en fait comme nuit debout en
faisait il en fait comme les gens qui
font des manifestations en fond et il en
fait comme les gens qui font des piquets
de grève enfonce rcd irruption constante
mais est ce que on peut comme ça à bâtir
une relation politique sur du long terme
sur ce genre de choses je crois qu'il
peut y avoir un problème
une réaction d'abord la première chose
que il peut aller ce monsieur le juge
bergès saint jeannais rebonds il peut
aller à la crèche les pitchouns habile
et voir si on a rien arrachés d'accord
il peut aller voir si les gens ont les
contrats aidés ont été maintenus ou
n'ont pas été maintenue c'est la
première chose lorsque vous proposez à
emmanuel macron effectivement d'aller
voir une crèche à ce moment là oui oui
et la deuxième chose c'est que ce qu'on
souhaitait su qu'il était actée par le
président la république
moi je viens quand il des demandes sont
précises c'est d'avoir la liste de tous
les intérimaires passé par whirlpool ces
trois dernières années pour que
éventuellement les personnes puissent se
retourner contre eux oui un pool
moi je suis désolé mais c'est pas moi
qui cherche à gagner contre emmanuel
macron moi je cherche à faire gagner
quelque chose aux gens à l'occasion du
passage des manuels mâcon sur amiens
voilà d'accord vous êtes en manque en
recherche du résultat concret bah oui
pour ces gens là mais si j'allais dans
ce cadre là
macron doit être un partenaire pour ça
il est un partenaire
ça c'est la première chose et ensuite la
deuxième chose c'est que monsieur n'zi
berger la ninja je pense que il
méconnaît le fait que en matière de
construction politique
il ya certes cette manière de mettre en
scène sur des combats particulier mais
moi j'ai écrit une petite quinzaine de
bouquins
j'ai écrit des bouquins sur le
protectionnisme donc j'ai une vision de
ce que pourrait être la politique
industrielle de la france
j'ai une vision de ce que pourrait être
aujourd'hui davantage la politique
agricole et en effectuant à l'assemblée
nationale un très gros travail de fond
je pense que peu de députés se sont
intéressés comme moi l'hôpital psy
psychiatrie de leur circonscription en
effectuant une d une enquête en
profondeur avec les en ayant des sillons
plus loin voilà avec des propositions de
loi et avec une analyse des difficultés
en cours donc voilà je pense que là on
retient vous retenez de mon travail et
c'est le jeu les moments qui sont les
plus médiatiques mais maintenant il ya
tout un travail de fond il ya deux
choses justement dans ce que vous dites
parce que quand vous dites la politique
sérieuse sous-entendu celle là ne l'est
pas facile celle là ça pose la question
de l'efficacité de ce live c'est ce
qu'ils disent est ce qu'à un moment pour
établir un contrat à long terme il faut
pas faire la politique entre guillemets
sérieuse et peut-être mettre ça de côté
le problème c'est que on se sait pas moi
qui choisis le terrain de jeu c'est
emmanuel macron qui vient chez vous un
pool et la douane vite se déroule de
cette manière là et là je vais on va
lancer un débat sur la politique
industrielle au niveau européen est
institué canard est quand même très
compliqué non moi si on me propose des
lieux de discussions de débats sur la
politique industrielle pas
particulièrement sur l'armé anti kurde
l'assemblée nationale des mici tu
m'aimais jeu j'y suis allé me sied que
j'y fais des interventions maintenant je
doute que ça soit toujours le meilleur
lieu pour ça mais voilà d'ailleurs c'est
un problème là mon avis démocratique
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les lieux pour
débattre au fond de caisse qu'on fait
pour la planète par exemple sur le plan
écologique
nous ne les avons pas donc moi je suis
allé sur ma chaîne youtube jeu c'est de
faire cesser ce lieu c'est ce monsieur
bah oui parce que je suis là on peut je
et moi même sur des questions de fond
mais alors vous avez évoqué la crèche
les pitchouns je crois qui a obtenu ces
contrats aidés et dont vous avez vous
dit il ya eu un résultat mais ce
résultat est visible par une petite
minorité de gens parce qu'effectivement
ce qu'on voit sur les chaînes d'info ce
qu'on voit en boucle c'est cette espèce
de deux 2 matchs chanteuse d'ailleurs
avec emmanuel macron on al'impression
effectivement qu'il est très bon sur ce
terrain aussi de l'interpellation
inquiète ce qui était un peu votre
marque de fabrique est donc
effectivement à ce moment là qui gagne
le match
est-ce que ça il n'ya pas quand même une
question d'image qui se posent à ce
moment là mais moi ce qui m'importe
c'est que ça soit il ya des gens qui
gagnent le match
d'accord qui est trois personnes qui
gagnent des matches à ces trois
personnes ou 300 personnes chez
intérimaire que aussi les intérimaires
ce jour là se sont représentés que pour
une fois la question l'intérim soit
posée donc pour vous la séquence avait
réussi quoi et alors il n'y a pas de
quoi casser quand c'est réussi
je le dis que je fais ce que je peux sur
le terrain qui est le sien c'est tout
mais je sais je ne considère pas que ce
soit une victoire que ça soit brillant
que je peux ce que je serais d'accord
vous vous adaptez à son terrain bah oui
sa manière de faire en essayant de
gratter deux trois trucs au passage dans
mais c'est intéressant
dernière chose il parle de
désenchantement il a dit il ya quand
même un petit risque de désenchantement
est ce que après 6,7 mois d'assemblée il
n'ya pas du désenchantement pour moi
ouais non pas du tout bah vous nous avez
l'impression d'avoir quelqu'un de
désenchanter en face de vous non moi je
bats je suis pas par moments par al
impression vous êtes un peu las et
fatigué quand vous vous interrogez là
mais je maintiens aujourd'hui quand vous
dites à majorer pas d'une payés au smic
à l'assemblée oui j'ai monté mon salaire
non mais non en tout cas il ya pas d ya
pas de désenchantement je trouve que
c'est eux c'est une arène après l état
de contraintes à cet aréna bon voilà
en tout cas c'est un temps que j'essaye
de vivre pleinement avec ce principe
hérité de boby lapointe aussi de mettre
deux vient de johnny hallyday un mètre
de l'en vie voilà d'accord donc pas de
désenchantement vous sentez prêt
continuer comme ça oui d'accord voilà
bon bah ce sera le mot de la fin parce
que je crois que vous êtes attendus pour
cette assemblée générale dans un usine
dans un indice et pardon bon bah merci
jean paul monsieur qu'elle chez moi
alors vous aurez enregistrées en train
de dire qu'on garde d'évoquer comme ça
s'il ya quoi que ce soit on saura vous
retrouver
[Musique]